Tony danker the director general of the
CBI has just been dismissed by the
employees organization with immediate
effects this follows allegations that
were made against Mr danker early last
month he was put on leave and the CBI
instigated an investigation by the law
firm Fox Williams they are an employment
law firm he stepped aside while that
investigation took place the CBI has now
updated uh the uh given an update on
that investigation the pertinent Point
here it says Tony danker is dismissed
with immediate effect following the
independent investigation into specific
complaints of workplace misconduct
against him the board wishes to make
clear that he is not the subject of any
of the more recent allegations in the
guardian but has determined that his own
conduct fell short of that expected of
the director General now at the time
Tony danker apologized for uh anything
that he'd done to cause a fence a
suggestion was that he'd made one or two
inappropriate comments it was certainly
not of an order of magnitude of the
allegations that the Guardian newspaper
has reported more recently which uh
suggests that uh there have been various
things going on at the CBI over a number
of years predating Tony danker's arrival
as Sir director General uh including an
allegation of rape at a party that was
held on a boat on the River Thames and
as I say the CBI is stressing that none
of that is related to Tony danker now
he's going to be succeeded by Ray Newton
Smith she was until recently the cbi's
chief Economist she's been brought back
there will be one or two eyebrows I
think raised over this because a lot of
this relates to the governance of the
CBI and the fact that they've now
brought back a former employee without
an open recruitment process as I say
that may raise one or two eyebrows but
the other broader points uh the CBI I'm
saying here this is the board of the CBI
headed by its president Brian McBride
who's the former head of Amazon here in
the UK it says the allegations that have
been made over recent weeks about the
CBI have been devastating while
investigations have been made into a
number of these it is already clear to
us all that there have been serious
failings in how we've acted as an
organization we must do better and we
must be better we apologize to the
victims of this organizational failure
including those impacted by the
revulsion we've all heard at hearing
their stories no one should feel unsafe
in their own workplace the CBI has also
said in this statement it has suspended
three other employees that's uh pending
further investigation into number of
other allegations and fox Williams the
employment lawyer that has been
investigating these allegations and work
race Place misconduct is continuing with
its investigation